[Music]
Avengers
the end is near
[Music]
hello IMAX movie goes hey IMAX fans I'm
gonna show you something beautiful
[Music]
show time a whole time axis is just a
completely immersive viewing experience
the aspect ratio is probably more well
suited for Marvel losing us for anything
because there's a lot of verticality of
character
IMAX up close is the greatest thing ever
because the frame disappears to fill
more of the screen exclusively for I
like spaces maybe sometimes you just
want to hang out on my face 60 feet
while an IMAX screen I think TV screens
smashed into your face I love watching
my favorite way to watch sequences using
that you will not see the full
experience unless you see it in time
[Music]
it's the spectrum is the objective we
believe sorts of movies size matters
the sound is incredible
the colors they're so rich
this film is best appreciated in an IMAX
rate
you just want to stand in front of it
and off
a lot of superheroes coming together
it's traumatic and powerful
sounds like the IMAX was the appropriate
call damn right
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you